samedi soir boulevard saint laurent à
montréal ça fait parler d'un 5 à 7
minutes avec les personnes devant vous
vous ne rêvez pas le speed dating existe
encore hommes et femmes célibataires
tête à tête discute 5 minutes puis
change de partenaire cinq minutes après
non ça dépend qui vous êtes assis à
l'air de cannes 2 et de l'amour virtuel
c'est devenu presque marginal de draguer
en personne et sans filtre
comme dans le bon vieux temps ça fait 17
ans que fait les parents organisent ces
soirées et c'est la première fois qu'il
lance une mise en garde aux participants
on va donner quelques petits règlements
maintenant on défend jean d'embrasser la
personne devant vous avant je ne sentais
pas le besoin de faire maintenant en
2018 nous spécifions maintenant parce
que c'est arrivé dernièrement où des
demoiselles m'ont dit que certains des
participants étaient plus insistantes de
mon-repos qu'il ya dérapage on veut pas
on veut pas que les gens me reste donc
maintenant on défend les contacts
campent les participants à l'ère du moi
aussi c'est nécessaire de clarifier les
règles
reste que l'art de la séduction c'est
savoir comprendre celles qui ne sont pas
écrites et savoir bien interpréter les c
est pour beaucoup
hommes et femmes le mouvement mis tout
est venu bousculer les repas par exemple
française aujourd'hui qui m'a dit ici
qui trouve que les québécois sont pas
assez entreprenants vers les femmes et
des femmes qui vont être qu'ils vont
sentir attaqué pour un geste que moi je
peux trouver banal il ya des femmes avec
eux j'ai été qui montre avec le geste
est complètement normal c'est ça qui est
difficile c'est d'aller à la personne
avec ses habituelles mais charme et ses
plumes à faire la coupure est il que tu
veux me voir mais juste les tricks
sexuelle c'est juste non jusqu'à 38 6 4
la veille à qui elle est d'accord qu'on
s'embrasse sur ces nouveaux contrats oui
c'est nouveau je pense que les femmes en
notre goût du travail à faire pour que
ça soit clair dans ma tête et qu'on
sache dire monde de dire que c'est la
faute du patriarcat de la masculine
toxiques ça fait juste créer une plus
grande distance entre les hommes et les
femmes
toute la question du rapport homme femme
ne pourront plus être le même j'en suis
à peu près certaine et c'est ce qui
nourrit la réflexion de la sexologue
jocelyne robert depuis que mots-clés moi
aussi a littéralement envahi l'espace
public ça dit quelque chose sur les
hommes sales et déstabilise
c'est normal et ça déstabilise aussi les
femmes ont le vus dans la lettre de
catherine deneuve et compagnie
combien des femmes déstabilisé par sa
voyons pas pu se faire draguer avec un
peu d'insistance
donc ça disait ça déstabilise tout le
monde l'aimait sa c5 sein de débattre
enfin des comportement maladroit ou du
harcèlement sein de débattre de ce qui
relève de l'abus ou ce qui n'en est pas
tout simplement comme la dénonciation
publique le comédien aziz ansari aux
états unis qui a été un point tournant
dans la discussion engendré parmi tous
une femme affirme avoir consenti à une
relation sexuelle avec lui parce qu'il
était trop insistants agression ou
drague médiocre après le consensus
l'heure est au questionnement
sims like qui connaît ce sketch
humoristique de staouéli night live en
dit long sur le malaise qui entoure les
discussions à ce sujet un peu tabou puis
moindrement qu'on ose être critique
envers le mouvement on se met on s'est
peinturé comme si on était contre le
mouvement mais l'évolution de la
conversation il faut avoir l'esprit
critique
il faut être capable de critiquer
quelque chose pour en venir à un
consensus surtout en ce qui a trait à la
notion du consentement et du non verbal
et en à l'aise dans les discussions
parce qu on and on n'a jamais rien
défini et tout à coup ça éclate de
partout en ce moment il ya une
conversation pour une soirée à laquelle
je participe où on n'a pas une
conversation a fini sa tombe pas sur le
sujet qu'est-ce qui est quoi ou vous
mettez vos link avec vous êtes d'accord
avec vous n'êtes pas d'accord
l'humoriste et animateur de l'émission
occupation double qui est du temple
croit que sa génération ont eu de la
chance et doit profiter de cette
révolution pour faire son propre examen
de conscience
c'est gênant de demander à quelqu'un
est-ce que c'est correct quand je fais
c'est ce que tu aimes ce camp je vais
tel mouvement est ce que ça temps
d'essayer ça c'est vulnérables parce que
le tout mais littéralement à nu avec un
homme mais je pense que c'est pas mal
moins difficile de poser ses questions
l'arrivée peut-être 30 secondes un peu
malsain où la personne va finir par
s'ouvrir te le dis franchement que
recevoir le message texto en me disant
ouais j'ai vraiment pas nécessaire soit
moi je veux jamais vis faut interpeller
les hommes qui aiment les femmes 1
et leur dit réfléchissez avec nous pour
traiter nous comme des victimes j'ai
horreur de ça
réfléchissez avec nous à ce que comme
femme nous portons je dis aussi aux
femmes
réfléchissez je pense que on va pas
aller porter plainte par un goût main ça
c'est vrai
saborder sa beauté ce formidable
mouvement qui est en train d'émerger
et comme le dit l'humoriste développeurs
dans le premier stand up qui osent
s'attaquer aux rapports hommes/femmes
post révolution pour gagner la bataille
mesdames il vous faut les zones d allier
parfait oui raisons complètement parce
que on est la grosse partie du problème
c'est nous faut pas avoir peur de
d'avouer ses tarder n'était pas d'être
parfait exactement mais j'aimerais mur
est un lien parfait qu'étonnante
adversaire tango je prenne un peu de
recul sur tout le monde vienne
un peu paranoïaque au niveau des gestes
qui va me poser je dirais que c'est ça
vous voilà ça va ramer le romancier ciné
goûter aujourd'hui la discussion va bien
au delà de ce qui est légal ou pas elle
a le potentiel de redéfinir toute la
dynamique entre les hommes et les femmes
[Musique]